all right so real briefly I'm gonna
cover some of the things that might not
be so obvious in the video so when
you're putting together your quad
depending on the frame that you have I
mean some things are gonna be different
but at the end of the day everything
pretty much boils down to these major
components and I'm going to show you how
these major components are supposed to
all be kind of connected to each other
so first of all what powers the entire
quad copter is your lipo battery and
you'll connect your lipo battery this is
the positive lead and a negative lead
and depending on you know you might
actually I've got on this new quadcopter
I've got a I suppose an upgraded version
of a flight controller in an upgraded
version of a power distribution board it
just makes it easier to use but at the
end of the day they're both identical
because the only things are really
caring about hearing connections are
these four pins where you've got three
pins each that's where your receiver for
your transmitter plugs in and you'll see
they're marked aileron elevator throttle
rudder and then over here you've got
your motor plugs this is what for motor
one two three and four so you can see
that this goes all the way up to six you
just will leave these two empty so to
power the entire quad you've got your
battery which plugs directly into the
distribution board and some distribution
boards will come with a battery plug
already kind of soldered to two wires
and some will not so if you don't have
that you'll need some 12 gauge wire okay
and you'll cut the wire to be I don't
know maybe six six inches or so you
might trim it or make make it longer it
doesn't really matter but you'll just
kind of one thing you have to do you
know every frame is a little different
and the way you're going to situate that
frame is a little different for example
if you're not putting on or Raspberry Pi
in a Grove pi you've got a lot more
space to put things where you want than
I did on my quad in this video
regardless you got let's say - you've
got a black and red 12 gauge wire and
then you can buy these little xt60 plugs
you would solder that in put some shrink
wrap on it
heat that up and now you've got your
plug that connects in okay so the
battery comes into here from there what
happens is power comes out from the
distribution board and heads to your
DSCs
okay
so this is my ESC basically the ESC
plugs in to the various like here and
here I say plug but actually what what I
mean is you have to solder it on okay so
if you have the power distribution board
that I had they had little bullet
connectors here so you would actually
take this male connector and solder it
to each one and then you just have to
plug them in and so that's why I bought
it it was Rick it was just a lot easier
to do because you'll notice the holes
here are pretty large and to solder
these little tiny wires in those large
holes is actually kind of difficult so
that's why I like that other board but
it really doesn't matter and especially
like with soldering here to solder a 12
gauge wire in there it's super easy it
just requires a lot of solder we'll talk
about how to solder here in a moment but
first I just want to show you how
everything connects so let me move this
over it gives much space I can so power
comes out through your distribution
board to the ESC and then the ESC here
this is your like your motor cable Brown
is basically ground so then your motor
cable let's say this is for motor number
one will plug in to your control board
so for example this is my control board
here so I plugged into motor number one
might be kind of hard to see but that's
those three pins where you got six rows
of three pins it's plugged in to motor
number one now so when that's plugged in
move this over now you have the ESC and
that's this is also how the board gets
its power the power is literally coming
from the motor board and so the now the
KK board when you plug in will have
power then you have these three black
wires coming out of your ESC this
confused the heck out of me because
you've got three black wires coming out
of you guys see you got three black
wires on your motor this is just really
irritating because you're probably
wondering how do I connect these
freaking things well from what I can
find
you actually just kind of connect them
randomly and I guess the ESC or the
motor just figures it out I don't know
what kind of wizardry they're doing in
there but bottom line you're not going
to break anything by you just randomly
connect these so what you're going to do
in the what's
you randomly connect them but you might
find that the motors spinning and
they're in the incorrect direction so in
order to fix that if it's not spinning
in the direction you want
you just flip any two of the wires and
that will reverse the motor so again
that's like super crazy sounding to me
but that just that's the way it is like
that is the recommendation and
everything anyway yeah so that was
really hard for whenever I was first
getting started so next is these bullet
adapters how do we use them how do we
solder them and all that basically you
take if you look at the adapter would be
kind of hard to see on the video but
yeah so what you see that little hole
there this is just how I do it I don't
know if this is the proper way but
anyway I'll take the soldering iron tip
and I put put the tip in that through
that hole basically just the tip anyway
and then you've got so much you've got
the wire so you would like drop in that
wire through the through the actual like
larger hole there drop in that wire and
then you've got you put the tip in there
and you warm up basically you're heating
everything and then I take the solder
and I feed in the solder at the same
place where I'm feeding in the wire so
this you know it might not be totally
ideal because here's the thing with with
soldering is generally what you want to
do is rather than you don't you don't
you know you don't touch the solder with
the iron instead what you're trying to
do is you're trying to touch the metal
that you're the metal parts that you're
trying to connect and you want to heat
up those metal part so that when you
touch the solder to those metal parts
not the iron that melts the solder and
that's how you're going to get a really
nice connection with these butchers
basically my way around that because
it's just so hard everything's so
stuffed in there it's almost impossible
not to be touching the wire in the
solder at basically with the iron
I usually just poke the soldering iron
in there and I leave it there for maybe
10 seconds and then I feed in the solder
and that's that's been fine I haven't
had any bad connections yet so just keep
that in mind
so so you'll slaughter basically this
one on here
and then coming over to your motor you
would solder the male end of the bullet
adapter to this side and then when
you're all done you've got both of these
you would just simply connect them okay
and for now I would just leave them bare
and I used painters tape just to make
sure they don't touch each other I'm not
100% certain that it would be a problem
if they touched each other simply
because of the circuitry in there but I
didn't want to find out because es es
and the motors are kind of expensive
someone can tell me for sure if they
know if it wouldn't really matter if
these two touched each other but I do
know if it touched your frame you might
be in trouble so it's only way I just
kind of wrapped him in a little bit of
painters tape just to make sure they
weren't gonna touch anything and then
once I was certain that the order was
correct I use electrical tape tape each
one individually and then I taped them
around the arm but you'll see that in
the video and then finally the real way
that typically you're going to solder is
going to be the following so this is a
pretty ugly board something different
this is the board I fried so basically
to solder typically onto a circuit board
you've got wires like this and the
leaves will stick up out through the
holes and then you take solder you put
the solder on one side you take your
iron and you put it on the other side of
the wire basically and you'll heat up
the wire first and then you'll take the
solder you'll touch it to the wire and
then you just lift up that's how you do
soldering you can glob it on there or do
crazy stuff and you'll probably be more
than fine but that's generally the way
that you do it you heat up with the iron
first take the solder touch it not to
the soldering iron but to the actual
wire itself as soon as it starts kind of
melting on there you just lift it up and
you'll have a pretty pretty darn good
connection you just want to make sure
everything's nice and hot and the
adhesion should be pretty darn good if
you do it that way
I do recommend there are a lot of really
good videos out there on YouTube for
soldering and stuff like that although
most of them are on circuit boards where
the holes are really small these holes
are really large and it's hard to do it
without just gobbing the crap out of it
so do as you will so anyways that's how
everything connects and that should
clear up a few things other than this
what you don't see in this little
connection is the receiver that plugs
into here and that receiver is just what
sends signals everywhere while I have
this this board out I will just say if
you look on these little screws right
here these are for setting the gyro
sensitivity on this board to set gyro
sensitivity on the other board it's like
a nice LCD screen but on this one you
turn these little things with a tiny
flat head screwdriver and it means
nothing to you at the moment but soon
when we're talking about calibrating the
es C's the way that you do that is you
set this yaw to zero which is you know
all the way counterclockwise so keep
that in mind if you have this board
that's what you'll do otherwise we'll
carry on with putting together the
quadcopter all right so this is just a
super sped up version of me putting the
quad together depending on your frame
and where your situating things you
might be putting yours together totally
different so for me a lot of time was
spent figuring out where to stuff
everything because I'm trying to put a
grove pine and a Raspberry Pi on here
something to pay attention to is motor
orientation some quads are identical
front to back other frames have like a
specific front and back the one I'm
working with has a specific front and
back but my previous one didn't
so once you've established that usually
the way that it goes is the black that
you'll have - you'll have four total
motors two of them have black tips and
then two of them will have silver tips
and then the black ones generally have
reversed threads and all that so the the
black motors are the ones that spin
clockwise and this is considered the
actual reverse rotation so black motors
are for one and three motor one is at
the top left three is at the bottom
right - and four spin counterclockwise
and they're located at the top right and
bottom left so keep that in mind also
remind you again carbon fiber conducts
electricity it will cause a short
circuit if you let your components
directly sit on it or touch it or
contact it it's the resistance is
relatively minimal so the conductivity
is pretty small but it will cause a
short circuit over you know after a few
minutes or so and that might be
your quad might be in flight you might
not notice it's smoking until it's
vastly too late so even just like a
little bit of electrical tape to cover
the electrical components will solve
this problem finally the last thing
before you plug in your battery the
first time check all of your leads make
sure positive to positive negative to
negative especially at the battery or
closer to the battery if you make this
mistake and switch them around you will
likely fry everything and you'll have to
start all over so that kind of sucks
just keep in mind though the connection
from the ESC to the motor that's totally
random don't worry about that one it
might be really uncomfortable for you
but that's just the way it is so that
one you don't really have to pay
attention to but be careful with the
positive and negative leads going to the
Power Distribution board and of course
to the battery so anyways
with that in mind hopefully you guys
will get your quad together and we'll
talk about calibrating the esc s as well
as the actual flight controller if you
have any questions comments concerns
whatever up to this point feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time